okay so uh so being
uh 9 30 uh i
will convene the meeting as uh chair of
division three of the house finance
committee i find
that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
the covid 19 pandemic in accordance with
governor's emergency order number 12
which is pursuant to executive order
2020-04
as extended this public body is
authorized to meet electronically
please note that there is no physical
location to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
which was authorized pursuant to the
governor's emergency order
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that we
are providing public access to the
meeting by telephone
with additional access possibilities by
video or other electronic means
the committee is using zoom for this
remote meeting
all members of the committee and the
staff
of state agencies with agenda items have
the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through this platform and the public has
access to contemporaneously watching
or listen to this meeting on zoom or
phone following the directions that can
be found in the house calendar the house
calendar has published those
instructions
since uh since calendar 8 to the
present 15 they're all on the gen court
website
so we we've also in that same
set of house calendars provided access
information
for people to join telephonically
we are providing you with the mechanism
also in case you can't
access us which is lba
new hampshire dot us and if people can't
participate virtually then
let us know and we'll adjourn and
reschedule this meeting
now all votes taken shall be done by
roll call
and so we can get started with the roll
call attendance
when each member states or present
please also state
if there's anyone in the room with you
during this meeting and that's required
under the right to know law
uh mr clerk are you ready to call a role
i am please please go
representative earth uh president home
alone my home office
representative weiler is here in my
office in concord
representative bean i'm at home in
guilford my wife is here she's going to
be leaving chicago
representative wallner i'm in my house
in um concord and my husband is in the
house
and i should let you know i am on the
telephone and won't be able to be on a
zoom
until probably after 10 o'clock ah
okay we'll come back to her
representative rogers
i'm kathryn rogers i'm in my apartment
in concord
and um i do have one person in my house
who's a caretaker for my dog
thank you representative edwards
[Music]
this is excuse me this is representative
edwards i'm in my
home office in auburn i have family in
the house but i don't think they'll be
coming in
mr chairman we have all but uh
representative nordgren i think she's
expected a little later
thank you um okay so uh
today if you look at the house calendar
the house calendar says that this is a
work session that we're going to hear uh
or talk about hb
254 and hb600
um it's this is labeled a work session
but since the only way i've ever seen
these things done
is using the hearing processes of the
policy
committees i plan on running this
segment as
boa or a policy committee um
for hb 254
i think representative kim rice said she
was going to try to and
come to introduce this and if she's not
with us then i think representative
wallner is a co-sponsor can
you're on mute ms ripple sorry
i don't see representative rice in the
audience
representative wallner would you like to
let me just say for the record um
representative waller and i talked about
this possibility today and
and what we agreed is that she keeps her
introduction
brief um that uh she'll be able to
participate fully in the
q a portion that follows so
um so so so
we won't be violating any rules i don't
think when
representative wallner flips around on
the other side of the
oracle table and starts to ask questions
i'm sorry representative walner
i interrupted you thank you
chairman edwards um mary jane walner
state representative from concord i'm
introducing
house bill 254
this is a bill that the bill addresses
the criteria for secure detention
of juveniles pending adjudication and
the circumstances in which a minor
may be committed to the department of
health and human services
in the remainder of his or her minority
um and that with that i will um turn it
back to the
chairman for um further discussion
thank you representative wallner and uh
appreciate your joining us
representative norgren i hope
everything's uh okay there
you you haven't you haven't missed much
it'll be a just take a moment to catch
up with where we're at
um so let's
bring mr de joy on who i think is
prepared
to uh talk at length and answer
questions relative to
while you're doing that for a sense of
timing uh i'm gonna try to have us
out of here uh before noon because some
of us have to travel to concord for the
one o'clock uh finance committee
today uh all right mr de joy
i think you're on mute okay there we go
good to see you again sir
you as well mr chairman and thank you
members of the committee for the record
my name is
john dejoy representing waypoint
uh in in the the issue of hb 254 i'm
also representing the juvenile reform
project
juvenile reform project has worked on
modernizing the juvenile justice system
for the last six years
and uh our members include the
disability rights center
uh american civil liberties union new
hampshire legal assistance as well as
others
um i'm hopeful mr chairman that my
remarks will be brief not lengthy but
i'm happy to answer questions as long
as the committee may have them i did
submit my testimony per year request
to mr ripple i believe um i'm assuming
so let's uh let's talk to mr ripple real
quick um
you you send us a lot of great stuff did
this one is on the website in case i
didn't email it but just in case i'll
did you did you include in your
testimony
some kind of a matrix to show us who
might be future residents and who
wouldn't be
by type i a mr chair as part of my
testimony i provided a two-page analysis
of the data provided by
the department that discusses that um
the spreadsheet matrix that you had
asked me to develop that i sent to you i
did not
share with the committee but i have no
issue
and i don't intend to use i intend to go
off testimony
since you have my testimony i want to
highlight a few different points
but one of the pieces i do hope to
discuss is the analysis of the
okay so to the committee i'm going to be
forwarding
um some work that mr de joy
did basically at my request and
we can talk about that with mr dejoy or
separately it's essentially a
cheat sheet for figuring out
what the impact on categories of
incarceration are
and i'm sorry mr dejoy it's going to
take me another 60 seconds to catch up
with uh where you're at
all right uh i think i'm i'm ready for
you
okay thank you mr chairman and as i said
i'm going to move off my testimony since
you have my testimony i'm going to speak
to a few other points
let me begin with a question that i've
become aware of lately that has arisen
and the question is why is this bill in
finance
now i can't speak with any expertise to
that but i can share with the division
my understanding of why this bill is in
in finance
it's my understanding that both the
children family law committee and the
finance committee
understood the potential impact this
bill could have on the census
at sysc given that potential
impact on the census it was understood
to make sense to consider this bill
in the context of the budget
because if the census is impacted the
budget could be impacted
and i further understand that there is
some
expectation that this may become policy
of hb2
to travel along with whatever decisions
you make in the budget
as i mentioned to the division
previously children committed at sysc
are disproportionately experiencing
behavioral health concerns
are often children of color and based on
past suspension and expulsion data in
new hampshire
our children likely be living in poverty
and potentially homeless
new hampshire has been historically over
reliant on institutional care for
children
in part due to the lack of
community-based treatment
we often hear about bad kids we hear
about dangerous kids
and the evidence of this is often the
fact that they are
committed at all and the fact that they
have quote
failed many other programs
the oca discussed brain science last
week and discussed the impact of brain
development on reasoning
when we consider dealing with a child
who hits someone
do we imagine we'll address that child
the same as we would a 30 year old
or do we address their treatment based
on the combination of their maturity
and their behavior any parent that's
disciplined
a child understands that a two-minute
timeout for a five-year-old
maybe may mean the same as a five minute
time old
time out for an eight-year-old it's
dependent on the maturational level of
the child and the same is true
with addressing behaviors
of children that may come before the
court
we know that in new hampshire in many
instances children are not placed in
treatment based on their needs
children are placed in treatment where a
resource
exists new hampshire has experienced a
dearth of community-based placements for
a significant period of time
which is why we became reliant on the
most expensive
least effective treatments such as sysc
the light at the end of the tunnel
though are the system of care
the federal family's first legislation
and the proposed probation reform bill
sb 94 is being heard today
hb 254 does not seek to remove
consequences for a child's action
rather it removes the most egregious
dispositional alternative
sysc from the from many of the available
options
now is the time to move away from this
ineffective treatment model in favor of
evidence-based interventions
not only are evidence-based
interventions more effective for
children
they're also significantly less
expensive
if i could move now to the the data
analysis has the division
has the entire division seen the
spreadsheet the department um
provided
well we could provide a lot of
spreadsheets could you
narrow it down a little bit so last week
the dcmf provided a spreadsheet of
charges
i'm sorry petitions at
sysc for the years 2019 and 2020. you
have that
access there mr ripple and if so could
you share it since we're talking we're
about to talk about it apparently
mr chair you do i if you don't have the
underlying data i'm going to analyze it
you'll probably
want to check my analysis against the
data at some point
but i'm not sure if people need it in
front of them when i speak to this
this is a public hearing and so we
haven't distributed it to the
to the world so if you're gonna if
you're gonna speak to a document i'd
like to share the document if that's
okay
fair enough putting mr ripple on the
spot
sorry
just one moment while i bring that up
all right kevin and also
mr joyce since this is being recorded
anyone who comes in
afterwards to watch it then they would
benefit from seeing what you're talking
about
while we're waiting mr george could you
there were three things you listed sp 94
system of care and another thing the
federal family's first legislation that
was passed in the omnibus bill
so it's being shared now mr dejoy can
you see it
i can't is this what you're referring to
sir
it is and i'm going to speak to an
analysis of the data as opposed to any
so analysis is your analysis on this
form now or is it separate the analysis
is in my testimony it's the last two
and i'm going to excerpt that analysis
as opposed to reading the whole two
pages
i'll wait mr chair until you tell me i'm
ready to probably all right now we're
ready for you everything
this screen is up and we're just okay
thank you
so again um i analyze the data the data
are petitions of children at sysc during
the years 2019 and 2020.
let me start with the the caveat that
it's important to understand that a data
analysis is not predictive
so this is not to tell you how many kids
will be in sununu
if two hb 254 passes it simply gives us
an understanding of the present in the
recent past
so based on the 2019 2020
petition data there's a clear picture of
how
it's important also to understand that
these the way these data are presented
it is each row is a single
child and all of the petitions
are over in the petition list it appears
from the extent of some of the petitions
that these actually represent multiple
petitions for some of the children
multiple commitments
for some of the children in the analysis
it treats every child as a separate
so there are more than 1700 petitions
listed
between 2019 and 2020.
a petition is a as effectively a charge
individual charges is what a petition is
there are more than 1700 petitions
listed
there were fewer petitions uh listed in
and consequently there were fewer uh
children
committed or detained at sununu in 2020
of the 1700 petitions
hb 254 to pass
92 percent of these petitions
could not not
form the basis of commitment to synonym
meaning that only about
eight percent of all these petitions
could form the basis of commitment
were 250 for hb 254 to pass
the data further suggests that were hb
254 to become
law that between 25 and 50
of the children on these two sheets
would continue to be eligible
for commitment if they committed future
offenses
let me explain that a little bit because
that's a pretty wide range and doesn't
really
say much a number of these offenses
have aggregating factors if a weapon is
used it becomes committable if a weapon
is not used
it is not committable that's not our
decision that's
that's the way the um the criminal code
is often written
if we assume that every one of these
petition
petitions that fit that criteria with
aggravating circumstances
if we assume every one of them has a
weapon involved
50 percent of these children would
if we assume that none of these offenses
in 2020 only 25 percent of the children
would remain committable in 2019 the
number was 33.
so that's why the range between 25 and
i think you know the question is will
come up so i might as well try to answer
it now
what's the difference what is this the
biggest single
difference the primary difference
between
current law and hb 254
is that hp 254 considers
serious violent offenses as committable
it considers offenses not categorized as
serious or violent
typically but not always typically
misdemeanor level offenses
as not committable and again i want to
stress that this is
does not mean that the child would not
be before court it simply means
that we're removing the dispositional
alternative of sununu youth services
center
but the judge still maintains every
other dispositional alternative
including community-based treatment
including
residential care and the others in the
list
in 169b will you take a question from
representative irf
i'd be happy to representative
thank you mr george could you just um
explain
i didn't quite understand you said 92
percent of the petitions would not
result in a commitment so
that's pretty clear understand that what
is the relationship between that
statement and the 25 to 50 statement
that you made
so one of the several of the offenses
and you can see it in the matrix that
was sent out in terms of the if
how the offenses are treated on the
defenses have aggravating circumstances
so for example one of the offenses is
robbery
if robbery is committed with a with a
weapon
or if bodily injury occurs
it raises the offense and that offense
becomes committable
if it doesn't involve a weapon then that
offense is not committable they can be
certainly be convicted but it is not
so if we well i i i i heard those words
and i understood those words
but i'm so are you talking about the
eight percent that
would not be committable uh but that
would still be committable
based on on your on this bill or
you talk about some subset of the 95 of
the 92 percent
so in the it's the 8 and the 92 percent
are just inverse of the same thing eight
percent
of the petitions are would remain
committable 92 of the
set of petitions would not be remain
remain committable in those numbers i
assumed that every robbery
or similar offense with aggravating
circumstances that
every one of them would remain
committable that's included in that
eight percent number
okay so you assumed they were
aggravatable yes which is how you got to
the eight percent
correct so essentially this 25 to 50 is
removing people from that eight percent
if they did not have an aggravating
circumstance
um close the 50 number
assumes that those those robberies i
talked about
had aggravated offenses and remained
committable
the 25 assumes that the aggravating
circumstances did not exist okay and
we're not committable so 50 so based on
this data
the most number of children that would
be committable under hb
254 based on this data are about 50
the lowest number if none of the
aggregating circumstances existed the
lowest number based on this data would
be about
five percent but twenty five percent of
the eight percent so two kids
twenty five percent of all the kids who
are listed on these two pages is being
committed
so there were eighty somewhat kids in
there were in the entire year of 2019
there was 70
in 2020. when i say 25
it means 25 of of those numbers you're
talking kids in one case and petitions
in another case okay thank you
i am and that's that's and i apologize
for that representative that's
a subject to the data the data combines
all the offenses
but then lists them by child so yes that
that is confusing and i apologize for
that
now that i understand now thank you i'm
sorry no
do we have a question from
representative weiler
yes
thank you mr chair would you go over
again the difference between
criminal uh assault assault criminal
threatening
thank you i will mr chair i will caveat
that i preface that by saying i am not a
lawyer
so i'm going to give you my plain
reading of the criminal code
there might be there would be other
attorneys who could give you a clearer
idea
my understanding is that simple assault
is
also classified as unauthorized touching
it can it can cover a wide range
of offenses from pushing slapping uh to
hitting
my understanding is that what is the
missing element
criminal threatening in and simple
assault
is as an adult and in the criminal code
typically classified as a misdemeanor
not as a felony
criminal threatening similarly is
classified as a misdemeanor is my
understanding
unless the criminal threatening involves
um
a bomb or the
release of a biological weapon then
those
so uh mr joy let's let's take a a
little pause in the in your testimony
for a second and do
a quick document review uh
mr ripple would would you scroll
through the excel sheet that you're
sharing from youth 84
and scroll a little bit slowly so people
can get a sense of it all the way down
to the bottom
i will and if i could just add since
representative wallner is calling in
she can't raise her hand but she just
emailed me and i think she does have a
question
okay i'll come to her in just a moment
okay
mr chair can i point out something just
as orienting the
committee to this spreadsheet please do
so in column b those
reference whether a child is detained or
committed
detention is pre-trial commitment is
i believe i can't see the top but i
believe uh
column c is a list of petitions
for that individual column d
column c is the count sorry a count
right
and the d is the is the enumeration of
those costs yep
and that's those two columns are the
reason that it's
it appears that these represent multiple
uh admissions for some of these children
because of the numbers of accounts
i could be i could be incorrect the
department could clarify that pretty
easily but it certainly appears that
these represent multiple
admissions so mr ripple would you go to
the excel
sheet that came from mr de joy called
committable offenses hb 254
and represent walnut for your listening
uh
sorry just one moment here no that's all
right
um i'm causing you to jump around and we
well if you let me share i can share
okay let's go to the top here and
and i'll explain this one uh okay
so uh i i've never really worked with
criminal statutes
and what i needed to really understand
this um this bill was to understand
what offenses uh are under current law
can cause a commitment or detain uh
status
at the sununu center versus what
of those offenses would continue to be
uh you can incarcerate somebody over
after if we pass hb 254
and so the x obviously on the far right
column shows that
that offense is so serious that whether
it's under current law or hb
254 it would continue to be able to be
uh incarcerate a child and then
if you'll scroll down and scroll down
this slowly the the committee members
have this in their
email but you can see
the offenses where we would be removing
those offenses
from the list of kids
and the yellow highlights indicate
what's where there is a difference
so mr joy put this together at my direct
request
because um i uh assumed
he had the insight to to do it
which he does and i i needed it because
i needed a simple way of understanding
what we were dealing with and
transitioning from
status quo to 254. so
so representative wallner if you're
still
hearing us do do you have comments or
questions
so
i i just got on zoom oh
okay okay thank you
um i was having some problems here this
i think we're talking about the offenses
at this point what i really like at some
point just if john
could um maybe do a little more
description
i think people have a hard time
understanding
what the alternative placements are for
these children
what they would provide why they would
be more appropriate
for many of these kids i think it's hard
having had um
the sununu center as a detention center
for so many years
it's hard for us to think about how do
we how are we going to
move kids from that
kind of facility how do we do that and
what do these what the do these new
programs
or they some of them already exist what
do they look like and what do they
provide the kids
and why are they more appropriate so i
know you're having a discussion about
offenses and i was
um i would um
love to have john finishes talk about
that and then maybe talk about
why other kinds of programs are more
more appropriate
okay so i'm gonna i'm gonna ask both you
representative wallner and
representative weiler for some advice
here
uh i i understand that since we're
hearing 254
that we should try to stay within the
scope of what's in 254
and be careful not to go out to boil the
ocean because
uh some of what you're asking i think
may be
outside the confines of 254.
so so since you asked the question you
you must believe it's a a valid question
within the scope of
i i do think it's a valid question i
because
i think that people um
have a hard time understanding unless
they've been
um deeply involved in the juvenile
justice system
i think they have a hard time
understanding what these alternatives
are
and it makes a difference when they're
thinking about whether they want to
change
who goes into the sununu center and who
doesn't
i think they just have to understand
that to make a good decision
that's just my my own thinking about it
i do believe there are some um
lawyer there is at least one lawyer on
the on the line
that could probably help in this
conversation
mr chair mr skibby who was a colleague
of mine in the juvenile reform project
just um texted me saying he is on the
line
and is pleased to speak to the legal
things that i'm floundering on
is in terms of the differentiation
between the offenses
okay so sort of i think to restate
representative wallner's question a
little bit is
and let's scroll up to the top mr ripple
please
okay so under 254
there's a lot of kids that could have
gone to the sununu center that won't
i i hear representative wallner's
question to be
if if they don't go to the sununu center
what are the alternatives and do those
alternatives
exist today and i'm happy to answer that
question
to the extent that i'm able to so the
169 b19 which is the dispositional
statute
in juvenile justice has a broad
range of dispositional alternatives upon
conviction
it runs the gamut from the child
returning home
and potentially receiving little to no
treatment
receiving therapy in the community
receiving some type of community-based
specialized treatment all the way up to
intensive in-home treatment foster care
potentially behavioral health or mental
health inpatient treatment if that's
necessary
it runs the entire gamut and what the
statute says
is that we should the justice should
always use the least restrictive
alternative meaning
when the children can be at home they
should be at home
what occurs many times is judges don't
know
what alternatives exist and they only
become aware of what alternatives exist
based on data presented to them by the
jppos and so when
if the jppo is recommending residential
placement
typically that's what the judge is going
to go with
i will point out that some of the
treatments that i just referenced
are only now becoming available
under the system of care this is where
the system of care becomes important so
treatment like
mobile crisis where trained clinicians
go into the the community in the child's
home at the moment of crisis to assess
what's going on
and how best to intervene with this
family that is just being stood up
currently
things like multi-systemic therapy
intensive
in-home treatment over a period of a
couple of months
child and family is the contract is out
and i believe the rfp
has closed and hopefully will be awarded
shortly that
those are both important treatments for
the population we're talking about that
will either
are online or will be coming online in
the very near future
they're expensive treatments but their
expense
doesn't is nowhere near the expense
that's budgeted for senior youth
services center
it also the key point of it it keeps the
child in their home
you know i mentioned that last week
what's common among
all juvenile justice children
is that unless they extend jurisdiction
for
a couple of years all children are going
back to this to their home
when they turn 18. judicial orders
expire at 18 for these children
they don't go to the adult system unless
they've been tried as an adult
so we ought to be preparing every child
in the community for where they're going
to be living which is
in their community and that's why these
intensive
community-based treatments are so
important
uh no i think that was i think um john
did a good job describing where where
what we need to have
where these children would go if they
were not at sununu thank you
mr chair can i add one more point that i
think is
is relevant sure so we know from the
child protection system
that historically
we have been a very small c conservative
system meaning that the system does not
is not comfortable with risk and
assesses risk conservatively so it
it is more restrictive than it perhaps
needs to be and i would suggest that we
have the same situation in the juvenile
justice system which is part of the same
division so it makes sense it's the same
situation
that we're often more restrictive
having difficulty assessing risk and not
being able to
to place the child appropriately and i
would point as evidence of that
to the um the detention survey
that is completed before children are
detained in the juvenile justice system
uh the department started using this i
believe in the last number of years
maybe
14 15 16 and at one point
in the last couple of years
more than 50 percent of the children
committed
to sununu or detained at sununu did not
score high enough
to require detention or commitment
evidence-based tool
now i know the department has revised
the tool
i don't know what the rates of override
are now override means the child does
not need detention
based on the scale but is detained
anyway
those high rates of detention point to
exactly what i'm talking about
is that we're uncomfortable with the
assessed level of risk
and defer to a much more restrictive
alternative
thank you uh representative your hand is
still up
ma'am representative
do you have a question i have two
questions if you don't mind
mr um one's an easy one
i noted on your on your spreadsheet that
there's one case actually two cases
where current law would not result in
somebody
being committed or detained in this new
center but
hb254 would i just wonder is that
so current law which came about
from hb 517 back in in 2017 and i think
you're i
can't scroll it down i think you're
referring to burglar
destruction of property appears to be
one and
unauthorized entries appears to be
another so entire classes
in 517 entire class
classes of statutes were restricted from
detention
because they were considered to be not
with this time around we dug into those
statutes
a little bit more deeply and that's
where you what that's
those statutes are where you'll see some
of the aggravating factors that we
contemplated as appropriate for
commitment when the aggravating factor
exists
that's the difference and i think mr
skibby can probably give you
a more coherent response than that
that's okay uh thank you the other
question relates to
just to make a point i guess i'm looking
at the
current at the governor's current
proposed budget
and in the medicaid area auto home
placements and community-based services
which are currently budgeted at zero
that jumps up over fifty thousand
dollars close to sixty i mean million
up to close to sixty million dollars
based on
um these placements i'm assuming
is that accurate is that is that what
that increased money would be for to get
people
the kind of people that would be in
sununu but if they're not there
that's i believe is broader than sununu
i think the department could respond to
that but i believe
you know the placements are not just
juvenile justice placements that dcyf
placement so it may be
child protective cases it may be um
juvenile justice cases
so i think that's kind of that's a
combination i think the other place
you'll see
the the dollars are in the system of
caroline in the children's behavioral
health division
the system of care i believe is at
somewhere over 4 budgeted somewhere over
14 million dollars
in 22 and 15 million dollars and 23 if i
remember correctly and that is
the continuation of the system of care
programs that was stood up
in hb 14 uh back in 2019
so i think it's both places um our
potential
possibilities for placement thank you
so i think what we should do is
um we've sort of none of us are lawyers
i don't think
uh or criminal lawyers so so i i don't
know that
we would benefit much more for from a
deeper dive into the
criminal statutes here what what i think
we need to do as a finance committee is
understand what we're about to do and
and understand what
maybe some of the financial and systems
implications are so
i i would like to bring somebody in from
the department
at this point and to respond to anything
that they've heard
and if somebody can talk to us a little
bit
about what they suspect the financial
impact
of hb 254 would be that'd be great
i i don't know why there wasn't a fiscal
note with this
bill but there isn't
so on that point i'll just say that the
bill ols sends us bills for fiscal notes
and we haven't received one
um so i'm not sure maybe just lost in
the shuffle it might
have just been an oversight that we
didn't get it um so that's why there's
no fiscal note attached
i don't see anybody in the audience with
thank you mr chair thank you mr dejoy
uh appreciate your testimony and the
work you put into uh preparing for today
um mr skibby and raised
let's bring him in i would like to hear
from somebody from the department but
i just wanted to make a couple of
comments um
first with regard to the data that the
department provided
my experience with this data coming from
the department is that it does not
represent
the charges or which children were
actually committed to the sununu center
rather it represents a list of all
charges
that have at any time been brought
against a child
and so it means that a typical
circumstance may be
that a child picks up
charges over a couple of years
most of those end up being disposed of
without any
placement particularly a placement at
the sununu center
and then eventually that child ends up
either due to treatment failure
and you know things not working out or
because of an escalating offense pattern
eventually ends up at the sununu center
and when they
run this data for you or for
other purposes they basically list all
the charges that are in the history of
this child so i think
it would be a mistake to look at all of
these
charges and say that any one of them
resulted in a commitment to the sununu
center the way that courts
work typically in juvenile cases
is that once they decide to
impose a serious sanction on a child
they just work with one of the petitions
they don't
they don't re you know revise the
dispositions on all of the petitions
that may
still be active for a child i mean one
of the
weird things about the juvenile justice
system as compared to the criminal
justice system
is that basically the the disposition or
the sentence thing as it would be in the
adult
system basically remains you know a work
in progress until the
court is done with a case and so there's
constant revision of these dispositions
including
moving a child from home into some place
like the sununu center so i think it's
important to understand that
you're not looking at a picture of the
of the things that actually result in
commitment to the sununu center
i think typically only one or two of the
more serious
of those offenses would typically
actually be what triggered the
commitment to the student center
uh thank you i think
i think another point i want to make is
that
typically what triggers commitment to
the sununu center
is is not the offense
the nature of the offense itself and one
of the
one of the things that you will
typically hear during discussions of how
the sununu center has been used over the
last several years
is that typically there's a series of
placements that are tried before a
child's end ends up at the sununu center
so that typically let's say somebody
who's in there for simple assault
they'll put the child in the probation
will fail they'll put the child into a
residential
treatment center that will fail they'll
put them into another residential
treatment center that will fail
and eventually they'll throw up their
hands and say we're going to put this
child at the sununu center
the importance of that is that you're
seeing the sununu center being used not
because of serious offending but because
of
serious failures of the existing
community treatment system
so that oftentimes many of these i mean
this is
getting better at a fairly rapid clip
and that's really good news for our
state and for
the children in our state but typically
what happens is that you have a lot of
placements that have very
under-resourced treatment
offerings clinical you know services
available
and so they end up being places where
children's underlying problems are not
being
addressed and so they tend to fail in a
series
you know in you know in a pattern uh
or as you say in a repeated pattern and
you eventually see kids ending up at the
cinema center
the last point i'll make is that
there are jurisdictions around this
country
that have basically said we are not
going to put misdemeanor level offenders
in our corrections facilities
um i looked at this several years ago
the one that was most striking to me was
that california has that
has that in their system they they have
just said we are not going to
put such a minor offender into such a
harsh setting as a corrections facility
even a juvenile
corrections facility and those those
jurisdictions
have have survived using that practice
and new hampshire can survive using that
practice
we unfortunately have a long-standing
pattern of using very harsh
consequences for very minor offenses in
this state as compared to the rest of
the country
and i guess related to this is that
what you do with a with a child makes a
big difference in terms of their future
recidivism
and it's not in the relationship is not
intuitively obvious
the harsher you are the more the more
you separate a child from their home
from their school from their community
the more likely it is
that they will offend in the future both
as a as an older child
and as an adult so public safety
suffers when you do that well you take a
question i we we we have just a limited
amount of time
as i think what you're saying uh
everyone on the committee has
has heard similar testimony before and i
believe we all share a very common value
system around
it and accept it i think i think the
a question they got asked earlier i i've
not heard an answer to and i think we
need to answer to
is if we don't put these kids in
the sununu center is the infrastructure
built today to handle the alternative
model if if if if it's
if we're putting kids into sununu
because we don't have
good alternatives today which i think i
heard you
imply is do
we still need those alternatives first
before we release kids into the
community into a setting that
could you respond to that sir
yeah i think that the answer to that is
that we are
you know approaching you know the later
stages of the build out of
of the system so that they will be
prepared for the minor
offenders that you still see showing up
in smaller numbers at the
new center so that you know the
department is in the process
of coming into compliance with both
the the requirements of senate bill 14
and with the federal legislation that
john de joy
mentioned so that my understanding is
that by the end of this
calendar year most of those
improvements will be in place and the
structure of this legislation is that
there would be an additional six months
before
before sunday new center would become uh
unavailable as
a uh as a sanction in those minor
offenses
so the effective date on this bill is
january 1 2022.
so it sounds to me like you believe that
that's that that would i mean if senate
bill 14 is complied with
and if the federal legislation the
federal statute is complied with then
yes we would be
ready uh for the effective date of this
of this legislation this legislation
also
allows for an additional period of time
before detention becomes unavailable for
some of those
charges okay representative rogers do
um no i actually have a comment that i'd
like to make um
you earlier said that none of us were
attorneys
um and not criminal attorneys and i just
wanted to remind you
that i served as a prosecutor and a
county attorney
and in fact practiced in the juvenile
courts so
one of us is in fact a criminal attorney
with experience in the juvenile courts
and i just wanted to make that clear now
thank you for the reminder you you
i did know that i forgot that no no
offense is implied
if i were to use humor i'd say i think i
promoted you by saying you weren't an
attorney but
but uh but that's just understand and i
won't take that as an insult
uh okay so uh representative erf do you
have a question
yes mr thank you so i think this is
great
but i still have the question that i've
never been able to get a good answer to
and that is
even with this in place it sounds like
there would still be a handful maybe a
very small handful maybe just a couple
of people
um who wouldn't who would still need a
place like sununu
is that a question for me yes
that was you're the intended okay
um so
i just to clarify are you talking about
the people who could legally be placed
at this
at the sununu center or people who would
no longer be legally placed
no so it sounds like if this 254 were
in place quite a few children who were
young adults whatever are who are
currently the sununu center would be
able to move out into the community if i
understand correctly
but not 100 of them maybe there'd be 25
percent left
maybe that's only two people i don't
know the numbers but let's just say it's
even one person
what what what is the what do you do
with that person or those people
kids the person who is still legally
um uh who could legally be placed at
some place like the sununu center
well if it's somebody who legally can be
placed at the sununu center
then there would have to be a continued
corrections like facility available a
secure placement
and i don't think anybody is making the
claim that there will no longer be
any need for a secure placement because
unfortunately
you do occasionally have have to place
someone
for public safety reasons and some
children do end up being prosecuted as
adults for extremely serious violent
offenses
so you will need to have some capacity
available
but i don't think anybody thinks that
you need 144
bed facilities to serve that purpose
so i i think that's the answer is that
you know some some jurisdictions have
gotten away
with very small more cost effective
facilities like a dozen beds or fewer
did i answer your question
representative thank you
okay so thank you mr skibby
um for for the department about 10 days
ago
i began a dialogue asking
for a budget estimate
of how much the sununu center would cost
if we brought the census all the way
down to
two kids for the whole year because
if if we still need a secure facility
i was just curious what given the amount
of fixed cost
associated with the sununu center
is if there would be any benefit to the
general
funds if the census was as low as
as two people for the whole year and
i would like to know if anyone from the
department
in the last 10 days has done a financial
now
i see no one in the audience with their
i'm really kind of disappointed about
that because that would be important
data
in the absence of a fiscal note on this
um so i see representative long
in the audience could you could you
question
representative long how are you sir it's
been a while since i've had a chance to
talk to you
um i'm i'm just curious if you i'm
blindsiding you i apologize for that but
what what would your thoughts be if um
division three retained this bill
rather than uh otp
uh thank you for the question uh mr
chairman i um
although i feel this is an important
bill that continues on our progress with
respect to
uh juvenile justice reform um
yeah if you felt that uh that would be
better uh
in address i mean you're you have an
important question as far as the uh
sununu center
um what what are the savings um
personally i'd be looking for an
alternative place we don't need the
large facility that we currently
maintain and heat
and all that uh so yeah no i uh
i wouldn't have an issue with uh
retaining if that's what the committee
felt
they would need for better information
thank you you've listened in do you have
any other general observations from your
listening in today uh
i don't actually i believe uh mr dejoy
and mr skibby did a
did a great job that was my um
you know if if testimony i know
representative rice
asked me to be here because she wasn't
able to be here
um so the only thing is i i know the
difficulty
of putting money forward today for
potential savings tomorrow um i get that
delivery you're asking
you're asking the right questions in my
opinion and uh
i'd be interested in those answers
myself but i
do believe that the state has been
moving forward and we have the luxury
of other states dispositions of
these matters that give them savings
and better services to their youth
representative wallner i'm going to ask
you the same question as a sponsor or
co-sponsor of the bill
do you see what what downside do you see
of us retaining this rather than otp or
itl
hope that if we retain it that we
will take a look at it as being
in how it works into the budget
negotiations that we do
around the sununu center i think
there's a lot of there's a lot of
people talking about the future of the
sununu center and
what other alternatives could take could
take place and i i would like to see
if we are retaining it i hope it's not
just to
um do it so that we don't deal with it
but we
really take it into this bill into
consideration as we work on the budget
yes ma'am i hear that completely and i
i given that i don't have awareness
of exactly what alternative settings
would be required
and what is being done to make them
available
uh and that i don't know what the cost
estimates are associated with the
diminished census at the sununu center
i you know i i just i i do think that
there's information that's essential to
this decision that just
can be made available but that isn't
today
so um so that's what i'm thinking but
yes thank you mr chair i agree with
representative walder and i think
part of the issue is there are a lot of
moving parts
there's sununu there's our budget
i think if we can make sure we don't
lose track of it
as she talked about and
the discussion is parallel to all the
other discussions about sununu
i think that would be helpful and and
maybe in a few months
we'll know more than we know now so i
think that would be fine
thank you thank you um
all right uh well it doesn't
it the house calendar today oh
representative walter your hand is up
no i just i just want to remind everyone
that we do have
a number of uh pieces in the budget i
mean
we've had a long conversation about the
system of care
and maybe we need to review that again
as we
um as we look at as we look at this bill
in conjunction with the budget because
the system is care
is crucial to this to this working
so um i mean it's all energy there's a
lot of interconnected pieces
so i just want to be sure we keep it
available and work on it in the budget
thank you i think you've heard me so we
have
two hands up in the attendees i think uh
ms ross had her hand up first and then
we could go to
uh mr cunning
thank you mr chair and members of the
committee for the record my name is
rebecca ross i'm general counsel
legislative liaison for the division for
children youth and families um
i have sent some additional information
to mr ripple this morning
which was the same information that we
had previously provided
to house child and family law that may
be helpful
including some data on the number of
youth that are
at sysc the tool that the court
uses as the detaining screening
instrument that you heard about
and the number of offenses in this bill
um in their actual statutory definitions
and the changes that would no longer be
eligible for commitment
um i'm i'm very encouraged by the
discussion of retaining this bill
i think that you'll see from our numbers
that the number of youth committed
is very low and has been been on that
trend for a number of years
specifically um one of the pages from
the data book will really show you
that from 2016 until now that that trend
has
substantially decreased um but we have
some concerns about
this bill getting out ahead of the other
changes including fully building out the
system of care
and knowing how that's going to impact
the system i think two of the unintended
consequences we may see if this is done
prematurely
is that prosecutors are less likely to
enter plea agreements for lesser charges
and have a longer and more drawn out
adversary judicial process with some
youth which we don't think would be
in their best interest as well as
seeking to certify more youth as
adults and drive them further in to
the adult criminal system when if we
support
things like sb 94 that would be looking
at
moving children and youth away from the
judicial process getting
earlier um assessments and
diversion and treatment in the community
hopefully we will be seeing less folks
ending up in the judicial system and
therefore less
um entering sysc at any point in
their minority um however if we if we
close that door too early before the
other things are built and in place
um we will not see those cost savings
nor will we get them the services that
they need
to keep them out of either sysc or later
the adult correctional facility
so we would welcome having this bill
retained having further discussions
about what the costs are
i will also um note that the fiscal
folks
are working on the the cost questions
that you asked i am not the person to
answer that and would not want to speak
for them
but there is a group of folks working on
the responses to those questions that
you asked representative edwards
and i'm happy to take any questions
thank you ms ross it's uh
it really is helpful so uh i'm not
seeing any questions
um thank you for your testimony
um miss and particularly thank you for
letting me know that people are working
on the cost estimates with a census
estimate of two people
so that that's that's great news uh
can you hear me mr chair i can you're
great
oh thank you um thank you mr chair
members of the committee um
my name is keith kinning i'm the
advocacy director at waypoint john and i
work together
um i just want to push back a little bit
on the retention of the bill
um there are i've seen from um
the child advocate maura o'neill dr
nomore o'neill that a small facility
of four to six kids can be built and
then
operated for about 1.5 million dollars a
year
compared to the 13.8 million
that the department is requesting i
think that the committee should
understand that that's 13.8 million
which does not include a million dollars
they spend on electric
electricity which is not put in the
budget plus some
amount of money that goes into overtime
you're probably looking at over
15 million dollars a year that the state
is running the sununu center on which
could be dropped to probably about 1.5
million dollars
to run a fault a small facility for the
remainder
of those children um i think you also
have to believe that there's a
possibility that if the structure is
built correctly
um that cost could be half if it's not a
completely locked facility in some way
or we can build it in a way it might be
50 medicaid reimbursable
which means that you're only looking at
750 000 a year to run a facility
compared to over 15 million dollars to
run the sununu center
i think i'm i'm greatly disturbed by the
idea
that we won't have sb 14 up and running
in the next two years i think the
proposal that's before the committee
um gives the department lots of time to
finally
put sp 14 and what sp14 is supposed to
do
in order to protect children um i
believe sb14 can be up and running
in the next two years which would allow
the children that are excluded from the
sununu center
to have the home-based and
community-based services that they need
um and let's not forget um
every day this place stays open the way
it's run right now with the children
that
aren't supposed to be in there um we're
damaging these children
there's just no doubt about it that the
kids don't that don't belong
in the sununu center are damaged by
being in the sununu center they need to
be
in community-based services that sb14
provides to them only the kids that are
a danger to themselves
or a danger to the community should be
in a locked facility and those children
are probably
less than two or three people that would
end up in a much smaller facility so i
would
ask the committee to seriously um
consider not retaining this bill
um i read a quote um there was a quote
from the
iraqi premier uh when the pope came to
visit and they said why not wait for a
better day he said people will say to
wait for a better day
but we must act now to get us to a
better day we have to act now
to allow the hhs to get the system of
care up and running in the next two
years
and then have a small facility for those
remaining children
that do belong in a locked facility but
the rest of those kids should not be
there and so
um i'd ask the committee strongly and
you mr chair not to retain the bill and
for us to move forward i think we can
get you the answers that you want
and there would be significant
unbelievable cost savings by not having
the sununu center open
thank you sir are there any questions
from mr kennedy
thank you mr cooning um i
would like to schedule an exec session
on hb 254
for monday morning at 9
30 on the 21st of uh of march
can can you can you make that happen mr
ripple with the notices
yes okay so um
so to the committee members think about
what we should do
think about if there's any amendments to
this like for example
moving the effective date from january 1
22 to maybe
23 or something so that we we know that
we
we don't cut cords too quickly
um but whatever let's uh let's exact
this on the 21st
if if there are other no other questions
i want to thank you
representative long for coming coming in
i i hope you
get to tell representative rice that we
treated her bill well
um so uh
okay so with that uh representative erf
your hand is up
i think you mean the 22nd isn't the 21st
20 seconds oh no it's the 22nd yeah
yes monday the 22nd
thank you for the correction yes okay
so uh with that i would like to close
the hearing
on hb 254 and open the hearing
on hb 600. i i believe earlier i saw
representative william marsh uh in the
attendees could we bring him in
good morning mr chairman and members of
the committee can you hear me
yes sir hi thank you
uh for the record i'm representative
william marsh representing seven towns
in southern carroll county and i'm
pleased today
to offer for your consideration house
bill 600
relative to funding newborn screening
tests which i found at the request of
the new hampshire hospital association
new hampshire's newborn screening
program is a wonderful program and the
intent of this bill is not to change the
program in any way
the issue i that i have with the program
is how they send out their bills
under current law dhhs bills hospitals
for the filter paper on which blood
samples are submitted for testing
the cost of this filter paper has
doubled in the last year
i believe it's approximately 146 dollars
at this point in time
and it is approximately equal to the drg
payment that medicaid pays
for a hospitalized birth and this is
expected to increase as more tests are
added to the newborn screening panel
fill the papers to supply and this bill
cannot be submitted to insurers there is
no charge for the test
performed we are simply asking the
commissioner to restructure the current
fee
so that these bills can be submitted to
insurers instead of billing for
filter paper the invoice could read
newborn screening panel
other states do this for instance in the
state of texas effective january 1st
and thereafter hcpcs code
s3620 was implemented for newborn
metabolic screenings
minnesota uses the same billing code the
american academy of pediatrics document
about one month preventative visits
recommends hcpcs code s 3620 for newborn
screening
if not already performed and a list of
cpt
codes most notably v77.7
special screening of other inborn errors
of metabolism
coverage for pediatric preventative
services has been mandated by federal
law
without co-payer deductible since 2014
pursuant to 45 cfr 147.130
this bill does not mandate any change
whatsoever in
insurance law this being the finance
committee it's appropriate for you to
consider the alternative solution to
this problem
currently 45 states including new
hampshire pay for newborn screening
through fees although some do supplement
the program
using general funds five states and dc
simply pay for the program out of
general funds
in one-third of states at least some
general fund revenue supports newborn
screening
the alternative solution which would be
equally acceptable to the hospitals
would be for you to retain the bill
appropriate funds for the program
and use the trailer bill to roll the
fees back to the reasonable level they
were a few years ago
obviously i prefer the solution
presented to you in house bill 600 but i
recognize
some of you may be less adverse to
growing publicly funded programs than i
am
whatever solution you choose addressing
the problem will help maintain the
economic viability of the various
birthing centers in new hampshire
and i will remind you all we just lost
the birthing center in laconia
uh at lake surgeon hospital thank you
and i'll be glad to take questions
uh thank you uh representative marsh uh
representative erf over the weekend it
sounds like you had some questions would
would you like to ask them while you
have a chance here
that's sure thank you mr chairman um so
reading the
fiscal note it seems that part of what
you're doing is shifting
medicaid costs back onto the state
shifting them onto the state not back on
the state
that would depend how you structured the
reimbursement under medicaid
when we discussed this at the uh rare
disease advisory council which i am
chair we were advised
by the medicaid director that
any reimbursement for the test would be
cut out of the
day rate for uh newborn births under
medicaid which would be cost neutral to
the state of new hampshire
uh any revenue that we generate from
insurers of course will be additive
uh to the hospitals and that's what
they're wanting is some relief from the
onerous fees they're now having to pay
can you clarify how to be cost
neutral to the state the state is half
of the medicaid fees
henry lipman said that that if they paid
for instance
75 dollars for these tests they could
reduce the day rate
for newborn births by 75 which would end
up
a net of zero okay i'll ask henry about
that then thank you
thank you any uh follow-ups there
no are there any other questions for
uh dr excuse me representative marsh
representative wallner thank you
representative marsh
um can you talk a little bit i i must
say i was surprised when i heard
that the way we were being reimbursed
for these newborn screening
was through the hospitals um
having to purchase these um filter paper
can you talk a little bit about
the cost of the filter paper and what
we're talking about here
for that has been passed on to the
hospital this way instead of
it being part of um reimbursements from
individuals or their insurance carrier
well i was not in the legislature when
this was first set up it's been done
this way in new hampshire for quite some
time
uh the rates used to be quite nominal i
sent you a paper of what the
rates for the fees used to be about 15
years ago
and and at that point in time i don't
think anybody cared because they were
normal enough that it was
a matter of indifference but with the
rates doubling in the last year
uh this has really become a serious
issue
uh plus hospitals finances are not what
you have a follow-up representative i
i do just just a short one this in no
way will affect
um the screening that is done of our
newborns i mean they
they will still all get the um
get the newborn screening is that
correct well one of the issues we have
is that more tests are being added to
the newborn screening panel as more
metabolic diseases become treatable
and insofar as the reimbursement remains
an issue i think there will be
resistance to adding new tests to the
screening panel
if we actually solve the reimbursement
problem so that the hospitals are not
penalized so much
for the newborn screening test i think
there will be less resistance to adding
tests to the newborn screening panel
and that would be beneficial to the
babies going forward
great thank you for your uh testimony
thank you
thank you mr chairman could you just
clarify the cost you just referenced i
i was looking at your i did you send us
more than this your testimony as far as
that goes
uh i sent you one page of testimony but
over the weekend i sent you an
article from pediatrics actually i sent
it to the chairman and he sent it to the
rest of the committee
and i'd be glad to send it again if you
would like no if we have it i'll find it
there thank you
so representative marsh my question for
you
is um related to uh
my listening in on the the hearing that
you had on
on hb 600 and
towards the end of that there were a
number of representatives from the
insurance companies
that that came in and asked
that we not pass hb 600
right away because they didn't perceive
that they had had an ability
to discuss the problem and to enter into
negotiation with uh with the hospitals
and um and i'm just i'm just curious
how you interpreted that testimony and
what your thoughts are on the subject
well there are lots of insurers in the
world and it's hard to catch every
single one of them i will tell you that
anthem is represented
on the rare disease advisory council
where this was first discussed before we
even drafted it into a bill
and other insurance jurors i did speak
to while flying
and the general reaction was they got a
pretty good deal for a great many years
and they were happy for that uh
we're not asking for a change in
insurance law the the federal law is
quite clear on the subject
um but uh nevertheless there's always
somebody who
didn't get the message and it comes to
the hearing i understand that
thank you for that i appreciate your
answer
i'm not seeing any other questions for
you at this point thank you for
introducing your bill
we have two members of the audience that
want to join us
let's go with dr tarella first and
followed by mr littman i think that's
can you hear me yes thank you
thank you representative edwards um uh
chair and um good morning for records my
name is
uh dr sai sharala i'm the bureau chief
for population health and community
services
uh just too far i just want to thank uh
representative marsh being a proactive
and collaborative partner
at work with us on these issues and um
uh the it's we we just want to be very
clear that the the fees actually
is meant for the program work so
it supports has has put in the
legislation the
fees that we collect it's currently 146
dollars for each filter paper
and that actually covers all our work uh
basically
the staff as well as our um operational
costs for the program
as well as the ch um the lab uh testing
cost
we currently uh conduct around 37
conditions we test for 37 conditions
and all of these conditions are
currently covered um these are required
these are
has um provided on the on the federal
level these are like the required kind
of conditions that we need to screen for
so for like almost um two years ago we
our cost first filter paper was around
and in the last year we added almost
like uh
600 uh four conditions that actually
increased our cost to almost
146 dollars so i just i just want to
point out that it's not for any other
purpose other than the testing and the
cost of maintaining the program
because those those filter papers cost
is used for
um thank you are there any questions for
i'm not seeing any uh thank you for your
good morning mr chairman um members of
the committee i hope you can hear me
okay
great thank you for coming today thank
you
representative marsha's bill here is
something that
uh the medicaid program supports the the
filter paper is
effectively a means to
pay for the the testing that was
described by dr shirella
um you know since the discussion of this
uh bill began that we've lost actually
two
places where women can deliver babies
both
the lakes region one that uh
representative marsh mentioned as well
as parkland and
in derry i think the the department's
very concerned about the
uh maintaining network adequacy um this
bill
in a small way it contributes towards uh
you know fairly um allocating the cost
for this vital service even with the
reimbursement that representative marsh
talked about the hospitals are still
helping to subsidize
the availability of a program that you
know
is not just a medical issue it's a
long-term cost to the state and all the
different programs that
support people who have those conditions
so
i think it's an appropriate bill i would
uh
just footnote that
in our fiscal note we were thinking that
it would um
it could be implemented with uh the
support in the medicaid
program um the fiscal note contains i
think a 225 000
total funds estimate it could also be
implemented as
the way representative marsh said it
could be just netted into the drg
payment for the delivery but i think in
terms of medicaid covering its fair
share on this i think the way we have it
described in the fiscal note would be
right so um
so i have a couple questions about this
um
would the department be able to
uh implement this law if passed
uh given that the effective date is just
60 days after its passage
after the governor's signature
potentially is is that enough time for
you
to to adapt to the change
i i think we we can do so
we would need to file a state plan
amendment if we implemented
an increase in payment um and uh
it could be if it was passed in july we
could file
something by the end of september to i
think cover this
and that would allow us to be able to do
that i mean
um there's also some a small amount of
computer programming i think we pretty
much
be able to do uh the 60 days after
if you were to recommend a number of
days after passage
what what would you professionally
recommend so that your department can
absorb this change
and include the i.t reprogramming sure i
think 90 days would be
um a little bit uh given all the other
things that
are likely to come up out of this
session if this were the only thing i'd
be very comfortable with 60 but
i know some more coming our way but if
it needs to be 60
and then to
representative marsh's observation that
he thinks to the
state budget that this would in effect
be
cost neutral do you agree with that
observation
uh and if not are are you able to tell
us since we're in the heat of the budget
uh battles what what the impact would be
on say the governor's proposed budget
so it could be implemented as
representative marsh
described but since medicaid is a
significant provider of um
uh delivery of babies in the in the
state and particularly in the more rural
parts of the state and those are the
more
uh challenging areas where um keeping a
place open
um for deliveries is is even more
challenging um
[Music]
you know i think that uh we had included
in our fiscal note the anticipation that
we would
we would pay the 75 dollars as described
in the bill and i think the fiscal note
says 225 in total funds
and again i think in terms of
what it what it's going to mean to us if
we don't keep all the places open
that are now still available
particularly in the rural areas this is
a very small
investment that uh you know will help
contribute i'm not saying it guarantees
anything but
i think uh unfortunately it's becoming
more and more challenging as the number
of births
are fewer and um you know as
representative marsh said this has been
a challenging time and you know i think
even with
um making some payment we're still the
hospitals are probably still
contributing
historically what they have contributed
towards this program and it won't cover
their full cost
so a couple times in testimony it's been
implied that if we
it could potentially be a key thing to
keep any of them from closing and
i i that's that's a little bit of a
stretch to me i
i yeah excuse me i would agree that it
in and of itself it would not be the
determining factor but certainly
you know there's just there's evidence
if you just look at it in terms of if
you look at the map of where to
to deliver uh children i'm it's
it's really uh declined quite a bit over
the last five years
or so and there's
you know for example littleton hospital
in the north country
is you know or not for i think
some cares act money would have ended up
closing as well
and so i think we really have a network
risk here
um and this is probably one thing that
we can do now there are probably other
things we'll have to do in the future to
to maintain reasonable access for for
people
our state so i appreciate
that and um as i think about the dhhs
testimony that we've heard i don't
recall anyone telling us
that we had a potential crisis of
birthing centers closing and as a result
i don't recall
any programmatic effort to address that
and i know it's bigger than dcyf
but i'm just uh curious on your thoughts
on whether this should be more of a
departmental priority something where
all
we got our eyes on instead of just
talking about in background
well i think that the the department um
has actually been
the commissioner of insurance and the
commissioner of uh
hhs have been in conversations about the
concern because i don't think
medicaid alone is not going to be the
way that
um that facilities are maintained in the
state
um and so i think that while it may not
have read
race to a legislative level public
health looking at
um you know there's been in the media
about births being done on the road
as opposed to um you know in facilities
that there is a there is a concern here
and i think probably uh the covid
situation
has kept both commissioners pretty busy
in terms of elevating it to a higher
level but
that certainly is an issue that we're
we're uh
you know if we lose littleton and we
lose one one other
rural one we really have a problem in
terms of access and again this is
not trying to oversell this particular
provision as being the answer to it but
i'm just saying we have
work to do um to avoid a crisis
[Music]
thank you for uh adding that perspective
okay uh i have a question for uh
representative marsh
uh would you have any objection to us
changing the effective date from 60 days
to 90 days
okay oh oh i see lots of uh hands up now
uh i'm gonna do um
ms minihan and then miss dunlap and then
tarella
good morning representative members of
the committee can you hear me
yes great for the record paula minihan
senior vice president state government
relations for the new hampshire hospital
association
um i don't really have testimony per se
i wanted to be
um available for any questions anyone
may have
and i i actually want to um thank
representative marsh
on the record for being so supportive of
this bill
and really helping us um to kind of
shepherd it through
and working with um through the rare
disease council as he mentioned he has
been very transparent with what the bill
does
um and getting input so um i just wanted
to acknowledge that and thank the
department as well
um both on dr shirella and
mr lipman um so i am happy to answer
any questions um and again this is
this is just um kind of a um an effort
to
just kind of not right or wrong just
just to address the the ability of the
hospitals to be able to recoup some
of the costs um associated with this
program again
as representative marsh and dr shirella
has said this does not change the
structure of the program
at all um but as she also indicated it
went and as dr
marsha's excuse me representative
marsha's um
information she he shared it went from
18 to
40 to 71 and now it's 147
um dollars so it's just it just
it's more and more expensive and again
there is an
opportunity as other states have done to
change this from
a supply um which just gets rolled into
the
drg um or the does the um
diagnostic um um grouping that they
build for or or you can just build it as
a as a lab
and this just is allowing that to
occur that's really all this does um but
i'm happy to answer any questions
um are there questions from ms minahan
i i have one for you um are you
do you think that the new hampshire
hospital association
is currently engaged in a strategic
conversation with the department
or others to address the crisis
in um
child bearing centers and that's not the
right term but you know what i'm saying
birthing centers um
hospitals and birthing centers yes in
fact um
mr lipman has reached out to mr anand
our president
to of the association to to have these
discussions and we
are in um doing some research
um to provide some information back to
the department and
um and like mr lipman said it's a
broader discussion
that we actually um have been um
having it's it's a very it's very
complicated because
it involves um quality of care
as well as the fine the financial um
impact of having a birthing um center
within a hospital
ex and the change in our demographics
especially up in the north country it's
a really complicated
issue but access to care and increase
ensuring that we have adequate network
for our birthing centers
um is extremely important to to everyone
um here certainly in our hospitals um so
yes we have um to answer your question
we have
begun those discussions excellent thank
you
so much i uh i hope everyone stays
engaged with that it sounds like we have
a problem we need to deal with
um all right so are there other oh right
there you are representative weiler
question for ms minahan no
just uh note to you uh mr chairman i
have to go
to another committee at ten after and
cover a vote thank you
do you have any questions for anyone
before you go or
nope it sounds like it's going along
very well okay
i would propose that we exact this also
on the 22nd
do you have an issue with that sir
all right uh thank you um
just dunlap do you have you have your
hand up
and thank you miss minahan appreciate it
hello thanks so much for bringing me
over this is sabrina dunlap i'm director
of government relations at anthem
um we did testify on this bill
originally we're we're really just kind
of puzzled by it because
we have not heard from the hospitals on
this issue i checked with our
contracting folks and typically this is
something
we would have heard about before um and
so
i can say i'm really still unclear on
what the need is to legislate
this issue um so you know we we've said
that before and
still listening to others speak on this
i i still don't know
really why this is needed um again this
is something i think we would typically
engage in
with contract negotiations and this has
not come up
um we we did not know this was coming
from the hospitals
um as representative marsh mentioned our
medical director does sit on the
committee for rare disease but
um i couldn't quite hear what he said
but i heard something like
we got a good deal i'm not sure what
that meant but um i can say we were
we were not um prepared for this bill to
come out of
you know even though our medical
directors on the rare disease committee
um so i'm not sure what that suggestion
was because i couldn't quite hear but
anyway just wanted to clarify that um
you know we're generally just puzzled by
this and again
i i'm not sure the connection
to you know the cost of these strips to
birthing centers closing i'm not sure
that that's
um totally accurate it seems like a bit
of a stretch
so anyway thank you so much for letting
me testify in this
thank you for coming in miss donald uh
are there any questions for her
for anthem i'm
not seeing any uh dr tarella welcome
back
thank you so much representative edwards
uh i just want to follow up on the
timing of it
given this legislation sits and we might
have to do some rule changes so we might
need some time
so i just want to bring up that to the
to the committee
just from our timing point of view
we're a finance uh committee you have to
how much time i think i think the
proposed 90 days to 120 days would be a
good timing
just given that where are where our
schedules are specifically with the
impact of covet so that's the reason i'm
okay uh representative marshall i think
you're still on sir
um would you have an objection to 120
days
i i really don't this problem has been
building for years uh
mr chairman and uh um i i think
that the hospitals will be happy to see
that we are reaching a resolution to the
problem and
whether it happens in 60 days or 120
days i don't believe it's critical
thank you sir anything else dr trella i
just wanted to add to the conversation
about the birthing hospitals we in
public health has been keeping track for
the last
10 years on the birthing closure of
birthing hospitals
and we recently started doing a two
years we have been doing a proposal
research proposal with
with people at up at dartmouth some of
our obgyns as well as
from rwg some of the funding is coming
to support some of the
understanding and uh we have been doing
some focus groups
and some of that information actually
actually is being
being uh funneled to our department to
talk about you know
what kind of issues where those things
are and we have been tracking this issue
especially from you know um what kind of
perinatal care the
the families or the the moms are getting
so that way we can understand what the
the long-term impacts of these the
closer closures would be on the on the
future of new hampshire
good i i hope i hope everyone keeps
collaborating with one another and
looking for some solutions it's
this is a departmental priority for us
are there any other questions for dr
trella
uh i don't see any hands up in the
attendees
so what i would ask you to do
mr ripple is to put an
amendment in and you can put it in my
name if you
just to keep it simple changing the
effective date from 60 days to 120 days
and and we'll uh exact that on monday
the 22nd
after hb 254. sounds good
that's my plan are there any comments
from committee members
if you have other amendments or thoughts
please please reach out otherwise no
we'll have a
full committee discussion on the a
division three conversation on monday
the
22nd with that
i think i think we're ready to adjourn
on
hb 600 thank you dr marsh and everyone
for coming in
and um thank you
so so the rest of our time on the house
calendar was scheduled for
and i don't have anything prepared for
this
work session other than to say
that i became i should have known but i
i really became re-aware of
uh of three hb2 notes
when the veterans home talked to us
yesterday they're in footnotes but i
guess they're also an hb
106 7 and 8 respectively i think
and and we need to schedule a discussion
and vote on those
um i i think we could uh
those are pretty i'm guessing that those
are pretty non-controversial
so i would like to add them to friday if
we could
uh those sections so that we talk about
them friday
and uh and and try to vote and vote on
them
so okay this is the
time of the committee meeting where uh
it's open to any committee member for
the good of the committee what do you
have any questions comments concerns
representative wallner you you got your
hand reaching to raise your hand and
you're on mute
you saw me so yesterday you presented us
with
a new budget document
and i have i have concerns about that
at this point basically it
was one person or two people or some
group of people's
um idea of how to rewrite the budget i
mean
now it's called the baseline budget and
in about an hour
an hour and a half from now we're going
to have a public hearing
on house bill 1 and the public haven't
seen
this new document so i think a lot of
the
testimony will be around
um house bill one obviously that's what
they
that's what the uh hearing is for and
without them knowing that there is this
new document out there
um i'm really concerned about us sort of
changing horses at the end of the
the end of the race here um
if if there was going to be an
alternative
kind of budget proposed
to work from i think
it should have possibly been and i've
never seen this happen before but i
think it might have been where it should
have happened would have been
that house bill 1 should have been
that document and that way
everyone would have a level playing
field for knowing how to proceed
so i i do have i do have concerns about
it
um i'm also concerned about
areas of the budget that are that are
quite complicated and i think we've just
spent
we just spent like three or four weeks
going through
the budget both house bill 1 and house
bill 2.
we've come across some very complex
issues
and i'm worried that they will get
lost or they some of them could the
potential could be there
for them to get lost in this new way of
budgeting
i mean i under i understand why
there is the desire to do this because
it's
adding back and it's being positive and
it's saying yes
instead of um saying
that you need to do some reductions to
the governor's budget
and that that desire to not be
cutting the governor's budget i can
understand
i can understand why this has come about
i'm just concerned that everyone doesn't
have the same information and they
aren't all working with
with it at this point um
and i'm also concerned about what what
kind of a workload is this putting on
the lba
because is this document going to be
loaded into
the budget system um
in the end won't we actually be
having a house bill one
that will show possibly reductions in
certain areas
um so i'm just just putting those things
out there
i know in about an hour like i said in
about an hour an hour and a half we're
going to have public input
and i don't think many people in the
public
even know about this new this new
document and so you might have people
who are
asking to not have their line
to level fund their line only to find
out that
in the new base budget that line from
the governor's budget is much reduced
and so they should be asking to add back
to
the base budget um i think it's got a
lot of confusion a lot of
a lot of potential for for confusion for
people
um but i'm whatever whatever whatever we
decide to do
however we decide to do it i'm here to
i'm here to do it
thank you representative do you have a
comment there
yes thank you um i agree with what mary
jane said
i also think it's very complicated that
the first year of the governor's budget
is his
proposed budget but the second year
is the same as the first year so
that's a lot of different
typing problems for
lba and i think that's as very jane said
is we're just going to add confusion
to the people who think they're
testifying
on a budget they have seen from the
governor
in the second year but now
it's not so i just wanted to add that
comment thank you
thank you for that and uh just to
respond to
maybe partially to both of you and if i
if i don't
uh complete the circle please bring me
back
i to the to the to the very fair point
that we may be overloading mr ripple
and mr felstad uh with a lot of changes
uh i've begun to talk to mr ripple
explaining to him
that i don't know the tools that he has
available to him
to manage our hb1 changes
and i don't know therefore if i don't
know the tool i don't know the workload
that's associated with that
and talking to him a little bit i i
think i understand
that that if
if if a line item is in the governor's
budget
then and we don't change the governor's
then it's easy it's already done and it
and and it's any changes other than that
um to like for example if we went back
down
to a fy 21
base number that would reflect a change
and that would be
we would that would require updating
manually by either mr ripple or mr
felstad
is is that right mr ripple
i am i am sensitive to the idea that if
we can accept the governor's budget line
that that works for the transparency
reasons that representative wallner and
nordgren have mentioned
and it works also for
the administrative sake of
the lba um and if
we get to the point where we're looking
at lines
and we're choosing between a few
thousand dollars here and there
i think the bias would be to keep the
in fact what
representative irf and i have done in
conjunction with
the republican caucus really is
we've taken the fy 21
budget that's a public document that's
out there
in order to improve visibility
of fy21 we added back
the hb4 items that aren't
transparent i mean they're technically
there in the public view
but because those hp4 items aren't
brought into
hp1 we we lose visibility of them
so when i refer to an enhanced
fy21 baseline
that refers to what the
budget is in the current year plus the
ad
backs from hb4 to give us
a clear view on what uh the dollar
amounts are
so so we don't we don't as a division
three
have a proposal on our budget until
it's the 24th or maybe a little bit
earlier
as i understand it the the budget that
comes out of division three
is never the same as the current year
and it's never the same as the
governor's proposal it's always a
different thing
anyways so we're going to get to a
anyways we're just going to do it from a
process of using
the fy21 enhanced baseline
meaning fhb4 is brought in there
and then we're going to take a look at
the governor's budget
and and and see how much
money is freed up by looking at
the ways and means estimates versus
fy21 and then we'll be in a position
to support the priorities we think
are important and i don't know i
fundamentally i see that as the process
that every division three in history has
had to do
one way or the other i'm just maybe
changing the order a little bit
but i think uh i i think it's
transparent in the sense that we're
using the current budget
uh we're we're making it more
transparent by adding the
hidden hp4 items uh and
we're taking a look at the governor's
budget and we're trying to figure out
the governor's budget assumed um
about 77 million initially
over the biennium more than ways and
means
so fundamentally our task was always
going to be hard
it was always going to be the governor
had 77 million dollars in the biennium
that we didn't have the luxury of
and when asked to help us
with that 77 million dollar difference
we were told by the governor's office
that it was really
their work was done they think that our
revenue estimates are too conservative
and since then they published another
letter saying they're expecting it
more revenues and and they've requested
more investment in various priorities
and so
because we're bound to live within the
means that ways and means gives us
we can never reach what the governor is
proposing we just can't get there
so i would rather have us focus on
the positive conversation of saying okay
given our current year we accept
that the current year's budget was
passed by the majority two years ago
the the spending priorities of the
majority
two years ago when they went through
this process we
recognized that fy21 the current budget
is something like 24 more
than an fy 19. so so sir so there is a
rather
large increase in spending
in the from the prior budget to the
in my experience when an organization
experiences
that much growth it's very hard
to maintain efficiencies and
effectiveness
and so when you couple the pandemic
i think it's okay
to start with an fy 21 base because
they haven't grown to the fy 21 level
as it is so it still represents a growth
from them from where they are
to what the current budget envisioned
them to be
so so even if we were to freeze fy21
it would still represent real growth
in dhhs from where they're at right now
but nobody on our side is proposing
freezing fy21
we see that there's a possibility of
taking about 100 million
about a third of it in the first year
the other
two thirds in the second year and adding
that back
we're essentially going to have to blaze
our own path
because we can't follow the path to
governor
pursued because his revenue estimates
were so much larger than
the ones were allowed to work with
so so we're we're we're kind of starting
where the governor started
using the current budget from here we
have to blaze our own path
and and we and we've got
resources to invest above the fy
21 enhanced baseline
and we may have more we we've asked ways
and means to come back and give us a
confirmation on what they think their
best guess
revenues are on the 23rd of march
if not sooner so but we're never going
to have as much as the governor
is assuming that's a very long answer to
your question
um but um i'll
oh i'll i'll give you back the floor of
representative
[Music]
walner um thank you
so i realize you'll never have as much
revenue as
the um the governor
had in his budget unless the ways and
means committee
decides that they would like to
reevaluate
their revenue estimates so i understand
i understand how that works i understand
it very well
how that works um but in the end
in the end won't the finance committee
budget
the budget that will be published by the
finance committee
uh it'll be hb1 as amended
by the finance committee be lower
than hb1 as it was introduced
which was the governor's budget
and as i heard yesterday
representative weiler talked about
i think it was 70 million dollars that
would be
that we we need to um
look for reductions in the governor's
budget
um and he
laid out how they might be divided in
division one having some division two
and division three having some place in
the neighborhood of a 50
50 to 55 million
reduction so in the end won't we
see published a
budget from the finance committee that
actually
is lower than what the governor brought
to us
i i'm going to leave that conclusion to
to kind of the statement of the obvious
that you just made but
i would just tell you that i see it very
differently
i'm seeing that we have a current year
budget that's almost 24
greater than the higher budget that
preceded it
and that we're going to use that
baseline of fi 21 and we're going to
grow it
more in the division three
recommendation to the finance committee
it won't reach as much spending as the
governor's
budget has proposed because as you said
we fundamentally are dealing with a
lower revenue estimate than the governor
and it isn't that we wouldn't spend it
is the same amount of money in the same
way as the governor
it's just that our rules don't allow us
to do that so so i
i choose to characterize what we're
doing is we're taking a current budget
which is greater than what the
department has been able to absorb in
the first place which
if they went from where they are right
now on the 11th of march
forward to the end of the year they'll
never get anywhere near
the fy 21 budget
so just if we used fy21 it's still
growth from where they're at and we're
not going to be satisfied with that
we're going to take that growth that's
still there
and we're going to add potential growth
in the to the tune of about 90 to 100
million
roughly split you know one-third
in fy22 and two-thirds in fy
23. so
so i'm sorry i'm not just giving you yes
or no to the way you frame
the question but i hopefully my answer
thank you i i this is just one this is
just a technical question and probably
maybe for kevin um are we going to be
having
the document that you shared with us
yesterday is that going to be
um available to the public is it going
well i i think i told him yesterday that
because it's an internal working
document at this point
and that it's based so strongly on fy21
that i didn't see a need for it to be a
publicly shared document because it's
like in
in progress work notes it's it's not
our proposal when when division three
votes
in a week or so uh our proposal is going
to be
about a hundred million dollars more
than this working document
shows if if the if the community wants
to provide
input and feedback they can
look at the fy 21 existing budget
and and tell us what they think about
the fy 21 budget
and how they think it should uh change
between now and the end of fy23
now that's that's how i view it if
the lba in consultation with all the
right to know people think
that this working document that's not
gonna it's gonna change daily anyways
uh needs to be uh hung on the website
i i'm okay with that i i just think it's
gonna cause more confusion than it's
worth
so so since i just answered the question
why don't you tell me the real answer mr
ripple
well the real answer is we haven't
really come to a conclusion yet
um i did discuss it with mike kane and
he said that since it was a working
document there was no need to put it on
the website
but uh it doesn't have to stop there i
could contact
house counsel i could contact others to
decide what they think our
so just just because i think it's
really important to all of us to be
transparent to the to the
public would you would you please pursue
that
to the next level of uh legal review
okay representative
do you have a comment question still
well i still think there are pub
there are people out there in the public
um
there are a lot of people in this state
who follow the budget
very closely they know different
sections of it
i think they are going to be confused by
this um
by this new way of operating here right
at the end
and they need to at least have access to
seeing the document
and i do hope for sure that we are
sharing this with the department
because there are some serious
between using 21
the budget of 21 and not
the document that we have been using all
the way through and that
the department has been responding to
they've been responding to house bill
one
the governor's budget and what we're i
mean it sounds like what's happening
here is we're saying
we're not going to use the governor's
budget we're just going to set that
aside
we have a different document we're going
to use that we're going to build from
um and i just i just think we need to be
sure that everybody's got the same tools
to be working with
so thank you thank you and i
i hope that um all of us
can understand the concept that we're
using
and can help explain it to the public so
that we dampen any confusion
this is a fairly standard budgeting
process from my experience
where if you have to do a budget you
take a look at your existing budget
and you make changes from your existing
budget i think that's pretty standard
and i don't see a tremendous value
in using the governor's budget because
we'll
we'll never have enough money to feed
the governor's proposal
so so let's focus on what we can control
which is growth from
i just have could i just make one more
comment yes ma'am we're having a
conversation
i i just i guess it's i've been around a
long time so
sometimes it's hard to for uh someone
who's done it
one way to make that change um
but you know the department has a depart
there's a department
process that took place starting last
summer
and they proposed what they felt
was appropriate for the departments
and for them doing their work they
propose that the governor
then there's the governor's phase and he
then
or she um does a lot of a lot of work on
the budget and comes forth with
house with the governor's budget
and i i i'm worried that a lot of that
work
is just being set aside and we've just
spent
and we've just spent three to four weeks
using house bill one
and house bill 2 as they were presented
to us
as how we've gathered all our
information so it's just
at the end of the process like this to
be
um given a whole new document to work
from
there are a lot of pla there are a lot
of people here not just
not just the people on division three
who might division three might be able
to handle doing this but i think there's
a lot of other people
that um have a lot of have a lot of
concern
about how the budget comes out i
i think we're all extremely concerned
how the governors or how this budget
process works out and that we all want
the best division three budget that we
can produce
and we i think all of us have
unanimously accepted the idea
that we don't have as much revenue to
put
into the budget growth as the governor
did
so ultimately everyone who's been
involved in this process
on a day-to-day basis since last july
probably already knew a long time ago
that the division three
product was going to be at a different
level than what the governor's process
led them to so i i don't think we're
springing any surprises on anyone
uh representative uh nordgren your hand
has been up the longest i think
thank you very much thank you very much
um
i think what we need i uh one question i
had was a process question
are the other divisions doing the same
thing are they
are they writing their own budget too or
are we the only division doing this well
as i understand division one and
division two uh
their numbers are going to come up
somewhere between
fy 21 and the governor's proposal
so the the their end result they're
going to get to the same result that
uh that we will we will be between
fy 21 and the governor's proposal
because all of us have less revenue than
what the governor was
able to use in his assumptions
but in reality division
three is writing a whole new budget
of their own are the other divisions
rewriting the governor's budget
line for line i guess i don't agree
with your characterization because we're
using an existing fy 21 baseline
and we're adding back hb4 we're using
real numbers
that have been really approved by the
the prior
majority as as the process has been
described to me
uh being in the minority could mean uh
having the majority show up with a
budget on the last day
and and not allowing the minority to
participate in it
and just taking a vote and and pushing
it through
based on numbers and i
am attempting a a very what i think is a
very collaborative process it's a very
transparent process
when i think an alternative approach
would be to spring a budget at the last
minute and call a vote and and
let the the vote to decide what we're
going to do
so we got a document from representative
earth
that was i think 80 pages and what it
showed was
22 and 23
and every line
was the same so the second year of the
budget
in every line is the same as the first
uh year of the budget so are
are we going to be going through every
line of the budget
or i guess i don't understand how you
write a new budget we've never really
written a new budget before so
so again i don't agree with the
characterization that's new budget it's
the fy
21 budget with the add backs of hb4 for
full transparency
and then what since we're using the
working document
we we had an algorithm that got us to
fy22
and because it's a working document we
said okay for now just carry fy23 is the
same number as fy22
but we all know we're going to add back
uh money and that we have money
uh to the tune of 90 to 100 million
dollars
of which in the first year 22 we can add
back
around 30 percent a third of it and two
thirds
in the second year so so
by the time we get done we will probably
uh
have in every line growth between 22 and
23.
so so will you pick a number
um an amount of money that we can add
back in
and lba will keep track of that
and subtract each day how much money
we're putting back
in or how does that process work
i think it's a working document and a
bunch of
the add back-ends we can kind of keep
track of as ourselves with ourselves
because
you know we can use an excel sheet and
figure it out
but but the lba will be
receiving um regular updates
and i will try to distinguish for mr
ripple
you know which accounts are ready to be
locked in and
that's going to be the result of some of
the votes we're going to take like for
example
yesterday we decided that we would ask
mr ripple
to give us all of the accounts
that had federal mon funds only and
we're going to vote
to i think to accept
the governor's budget on those federal
lines and that'll put
a portion of the work away as we go
through the budget and the few remaining
work days that we have
we're going to try to agree on some
areas like you know i think
i think we probably are are all
very close to agreeing on the veterans
home and
glencliff for example you know
and i forget exactly like if you will
tell us what line
the health equity line was that you that
you suggested that we
we agreed to uh we probably
will agree to your proposals
i do want this to be collegial i do want
your input reflected
i do want this to be a transparent
process
i do realize that there's an alternative
where we could spring something on you
at the last moment and just
go straight to a vote and i don't want
i i just worry that the public will be
totally left out of this not knowing
today when they testify
that they're testifying on hopefully
having their
certain line item put back in the budget
because now
these things are already in the budget
all right thank you very much
representative rogers your hand has been
up
um i in fairness representative erf's
hand was up before mine but i'm happy to
go
um i have a few questions if we're
bringing in
written amendments should they be worded
to amend the document house bill won or
should they be worded
to amend the um representative
document that he gave to us those lines
how do we want to do that
so if you're if you're amending hb2 uh
we have a schedule that we've shared
talking about
which sections we're going to talk about
in on on each day
um right on hospital one okay if you
haven't proposed amendments on
i'm not actually sure exactly how that
level of detail works
i have imagined what we would do is we
would
be talking as a committee division three
off of an excel document and deciding on
hb1
how we want to invest the resources we
have available
so you're not going to require written
amendments we could just talk about them
if we
i i want this to be a collaborative
process and i think
discussion and brainstorming is best
done if we've got a
live excel sheet and and that and then
if we can get comfortable
that we've resourced it properly
at that point i'd turn it over to mr
ripple and say please
make this an amendment and and then
we're ready to vote because we've
already had the discussion
okay i just wanted to make sure how you
wanted to do it
the other concern that i have is um and
i know that
perception is sometimes reality but my
concern
is that um when we come out with the
document that
um your your yours and represent earth's
document as our proposed budget
um and we're not any longer using house
bill one
um that your explanation needs to be
a little bit um clearer
because i fear that the public will will
look at this as somewhat of an
obfuscation and i'm not saying it is i'm
saying
perception because the document has not
been released to the public
so i would urge you and urge mr ripple
that
to err on the side of caution um and to
as i i understand you're saying the
document will change rapidly
but releasing it to the public could go
a long way
now to reducing anything in the future
of people saying that it's an
obfuscation or ability to hide or the
last minute
if the sooner they they have that
document even if it is going to change
rapidly then you take away any kind of
um
possible people saying they didn't have
it they didn't know it was there and so
forth
so i would urge you to err on the the
side of caution
by releasing it and putting it on the
website at least
i don't see where it's a problem that
anybody sees it
um even if it might be out of date the
minute you put it on there
at least it's there that people see the
document we're working off of at one
point
um my grandfather always said the only
thing that does well in the dark is
cockroaches so
um i think it might be helpful to put it
on there so that people can see what
we're working off of
and just because then people won't
when they can't see something is when
people complain and put all kinds of um
people's motives for doing it that's
just
yes so so i've found that
you can never communicate perfectly to
100 of the people anyways and people who
choose to
look at something negatively or that's
they're going to exercise that choice
but i just want to put the next eight
days into context
the eight in the next eight days is a
tiny drop of time between
when the fy 21 budget was approved
two years ago and hb4 got approved on
top of it
the the working document that we're
using does us a favor
by taking that hb 21 existing budget
that's been out there for two years
and merging into it the hb4 items that
have also have been out there for a
couple of years
so it gives us visibility into what's
been there for two years
when we finish our work in eight days
it's we're nowhere near done the state's
nowhere near done
our division three work will go to a
full finance committee
a week or so later where uh public
comment can be reached
uh then the from the finance committee
it goes to the whole house
if the whole house passes it it goes to
the senate and goes through all of this
process all over again
and then it goes into the committee a
conference which is probably
more in the dark than anything we're
doing
in in the next eight days everything we
do
is going to be broadcast live
so so in terms of transparency of the
work
performance over the next eight days i
i i think we're going to be extremely
transparent
and because i agree with your point you
know things don't
you know sunshine is the best
disinfectant so
that did that address your concerns
maybe i
not in the way you wanted me to but i
think
what do you think i just think the more
you put in the public view the better
and i would urge you to
put the document in public thank you
that's all thank you i have a lot of
work in the next eight days and things
are going to be changing so much
that it it actually in reality is
impossible
to communicate to everyone exactly what
the existing
status is in the instant so i i don't
i don't know that it's even an
achievable objective to
to be fully transparent as we're talking
to one another beyond
doing this representative erf do you
have a
comment emmy
thank you mr chairman i have a very
different
perspective i view this process as being
very similar to what we went through
two years ago the only confusion that's
been created in the public's eye is what
our committee is creating
i fully expect the people testifying
this afternoon which hopefully
get there in time would speak to the
governor's budget
that that's what i would be doing that's
what i would expect them to be doing i
don't
that's absolutely would work perfectly
if you looked at the document that i
provided you'll notice that
i've simply i've noted where the
government's
elements have picked up in the
underlying document
and we as the chairman has mentioned
we've already or we're planning to vote
on a whole bunch of accounts
soon that will pick up the governor's
part of the budget
i don't view the there be any more work
for the lba
why would they be doing anything until
we pick
we tell them they'll tell them what
particular account is going to hold is
it going to hold the governor's numbers
is it going to hold budget 21 numbers is
going to hold
other numbers i recall going through and
changing
many of the governor's numbers many of
the governor's numbers two years ago
and that was all after the public
hearings so
the public comes and they tell us what
they do what like about the governor
what they don't like about the governor
we're just basically looking at it from
a
from a different starting point i guess
you could view it that way because we
have to reduce
two years ago it was all about
increasing it was a different
a different role that we were
that we were taking i guess i don't see
the need to
post this budget it's not a budget it
simply shows two different perspectives
and how they can be
combined it doesn't say that this is how
they are combined
so we will basically be able to pick and
choose and we can pick a third way just
as two years ago
we often picked a third way it just
happened that two years ago
it typically was a much higher way than
the governor's budget
this year we have to go lower so
i don't know why you want to confuse
people about look at some other
thing that what they're thinking about
let's not imply intent
representative earth we we we're not
even hiding
we're just hearing questions from from
everyone
but we let's not assume that we know
what their intent is
okay i apologize what would i use i've
been planning time i didn't need to
i take it back and honestly i'm not
trying to imply intent i'm just i know
i just just trying to keep it you know
collegial
well i'm just listening to the
discussion having been through this
myself two years ago
and i don't see the points that are
being made
being different from what it was two
years ago
other than i understand what we're
starting from two years ago they started
we started from a different place but
from the public's perspective
it's always the governor's budget okay
i'll just stop i guess
i've got to get going anyway i'm gonna
i'm gonna try to wind down in just a
couple of minutes because i i have to
finish getting dressed and put uh drive
up to concord so
so representative wallner waller plea
please
share with us what you're thinking well
i just i have one i just have one
further question and i'd just be
interested to know
um have has this new way of doing the
budget
uh been discussed with the governor is
the governor's office aware
of um how we're going to proceed because
i know that
in the past when the governor's office
has been
really involved in watching the house
and working with the house around the
budget so i just wondered if
if the governor's office has been
actively
participating in uh this new way of
going forward
so so two folks from
the governor's office accepted our
invitation
to talk to uh the division iii
leadership
about i don't know it's been three weeks
ago
and one of them is in the attendees now
as i've watched over the
last uh few days it seems like one or
both of them have always been in the
attendees list
we i made an overt request
for them to participate in our process
and the the essence of the answer i got
back was that the governor thinks
we're going to have more revenue we've
based our budget
on that revenue estimate and
the house you have a different process
because you use different revenue
numbers and
we are in no position to help you figure
out
what numbers you're going to use other
than the governor's numbers so
so so requests were made
assistance was not
i'll just leave it there so to answer
your question
i think the governor's office knows
exactly what we're doing and why we're
doing it and they were invited
invited to participate as assertively as
they wanted to
thank you yes ma'am
i think at this point we have to go
because some of us
need to get to conquer um and
um i'm not seeing any hands up in the
attendees or
in amongst the committee members um
i i just would assure you as
colleagues i've always expected that
we're not going to agree
on the final numbers but i
have always wanted to have this being a
very open
very transparent and very collegial
process
with with everyone and and today
uh i think we maintain that even though
we can start to see that we have
different viewpoints on
on the way things should be so so i
appreciate everyone's
courtesy and i apologize if i was
a little tenser than i should be so um
not seeing any further comments i
think we're adjourned and then wait a
second before we adjourn
what we're getting together at one
o'clock today obviously
but then we have a budget work session
tomorrow
where we've scheduled talking about
sections 21
23 24 25 28 and then
um i have a note here lapse rates kevin
do you do you know what that note means
mr ripple
i'm not sure i think that meant you were
going to tell us about
teach us another time one more bite at
the apple
on how lapse rates get factored into
the the budgets so that so if we say
a billion dollars but you have to lapse
uh 50 million dollars you know what how
that has worked historically
i think i think it's a tutorial sure
sounds good
all right so uh i'll see you all
shortly uh with that today's